THIS? BECAUSE OF THHO
DYING RIGHT NOW  UKRAINE.CA YOU
E RISKS YO DECIDE TO
TAKE T?OT  ARE
I KNOW ABOUT THE CONSEQUENCES
HI WELL.SKND ERYSUFFERIN UKRAINA
I CA. D
HE THIS JOI WAS UL
I HIM AND I
O DO THIS
-T
DECISIONTHE PROCESTHAT Y.
YOU KNOE RISKS
T AND
OTHE YOUR MILY.
CISIONMA?OT WE
WHAT'S H RIGHT NOW>>HET DIFFICUA
TO LIVE WITH LIVESN THIS
PE.
WORKING A
DIFFICULT EDITOR AND THINKING
ABOUT INE, IT IS REALLY
S. WK BUL AGRE
>> ALESANDRA YOU
W?PPORT YOURSELF AHA
DOT I N'T KNOW WHAT TO DO INTU.
I AM JUSYINGO WAKEINGH THE DAY,T
NO>> A FEARFUL?
>> YES COUM FEARFUL.
VE LIFE.
>>
EGDOOUY
REGRETS?
>>O REGRETS. NO EXCUSEFOR
NOTHISO K ABOUT THIS AND FOR VE
THINKKAY THAT'S
SOMETHTHATON'T DISTURB ME
OR SOMET
I THIN ALL OR TH
AYPEOPLE THINK PEOPLE INSIDEUSNO
SOMETHI.
THYBTI TY FUND S PEOPON
TO YOUR UKRAINIANS OR INIAN PEOE
SIA